j'ai déjà été dans un sex-shop comme ça
pour le jeu débute d'ailleurs charles
charente vienne pour le week end
j'essaye de toujours trouver des trucs
sympas alors oui alors jugés une fois
pas aujourd'hui mais c'est pas des
maisons non sélection du pays basque moi
j'ai prise des mimiques du cash mais en
fait j'avais pas à ces jeunes parce que
j'ai acheté plusieurs choses on s'en
fout mais quand mon pays mes petites
infos personnes quand vous payer en
carte de crédit c'est le seul endroit où
sur le ticket de caisse
il n'y a absolument rien marquer sauf le
montant à when we et où le ticket d elle
que très remarquée sexy show bien
pourquoi masquer leur bien mais il faut
que je vous donne sa mère est lacunaire
de crédit circule et vous avez déjà été
lancés le choc
oui ça m'est arrivé non j'adore parce qu
elle elle dit tout sur le même faux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était pour le même reportage et avec
maxime qui appelle maxime gainey avec
mathis anormaux on est bien sûr vous
savez avec mathieu béda nîmes
non ben non non mais un jour j'ai jamais
été dans un sex-shop a très bien fait on
les regarde